[Music]
hello and welcome back to another night
of chess on psychology
today
we are
wrapping up sicilian
oh good god
this is roser
which i wanted to call razor i don't
know if they actually got that in there
but
but we are going to shave off sicilian
with razor roser
we've done dragon myroxy
a bunch of night the earth bunch of
cheveningen some sweatshnikov
kalashnikov
some sidelines that nobody ever thought
of a bunch of pulse and con everything
everything so
don't you come here asking me about
other sicilians
if you mean if you have nice games that
you want me to analyze definitely i will
but tonight is the last one
also big probably because tracy was
about to grow a tail
by how much she hated me doing sicilians
so
we
are officially wrapping it up and as a
special bonus
i was not able to load this on leeches
after about half hour of fighting with
leeches personally and so we're doing
chess base today going old school
so
i am ready to jump in kind of checking
to see if there's anything from the chat
any questions any
feelings yeah unfortunately leeches
didn't really couldn't it just wouldn't
let me make it the past six moves and i
i was upset about that but we will be
using leeches uh next hour so
if you have games already put it on
leeches in about an hour probably a
little less switch to twitch
analyze your games all right
enough chit chat let's go wrap up
sicilian shave it off
i need some
non-opening streams
oh i cannot do the mouse anymore huh now
i miss leeches
okay so
last week we or last few weeks we spent
a bunch a bunch of bunch of times
talking about e6 or e5 actually e6 i
think we did way earlier insisted on
four night style
and then we talked about like the d6
with e5 and everything so now we are
going for roser i've had some very
interesting experiences with it
and it's weird because
um i had one of the early on coaches
that i had over 10 years ago rest in
peace que venus
he was the one who kind of gave me the
short-term sweets here's roser this is
what you gotta look out for so i'm gonna
try to do something like that for you
too
there are
a lot a lot a lot of really really great
classic games so don't just rely on what
i'm telling you but take your time with
the opening make sure that you feel
comfortable with it i'm gonna give you
my
expert experience and my expertise on it
but it's up to you to
cater to how you want put your games and
yeah i have a few students who do that
whenever i teach them something they go
and add to it and show me and i'm very
proud of them
all right so
first things first
let's talk about let's put this the
other way and then let's talk about
queen a5 just because why not
uh queen i5 is not necessarily the main
line
the one things that the things you want
to watch out for is bishop d7 e6 this is
kind of like it's a lot of it just
transposes so you don't necessarily have
to
just look for one line a lot of it's
kind of transposes together
the big ideas is let me actually see if
i can no that's not it that is it yeah
so a lot of the things that are going to
happen
are surrounding this ideas black that's
what black is most likely going to try
and do and as white what we might want
to do is we have to figure out when to
take it we have to because then when
black takes it then we have interesting
ideas
from white which
one of them
is
the
lawn castle idea followed by if you can
somehow fixate
these double pawns and i know there's
too many arrows this is probably giving
you a mini headache and
i apologize for that but i kind of
wanted to give you the overview of this
is what white wants this is what black
ones as white if they could manage to
get those f pawns fixated together maybe
get a bishop with the h5 so we're
attacking f7
and that is going to be a dream come
true
all right so you probably have a little
bit more info now
let's go
let's talk about e6 first just because i
see that i had a very painful loss in it
this was very early on when i had just
started playing the main line in
sicilian so i was not very comfortable
in it
um
here i made the mistake and i went
bishop h4 sorry i made the mistake and i
went bishop e3
yes i did
i'll tell you why this is a mistake
i went to bishop e3
because i thought that i need to do f3
g4 and i thought my bishop on e3 makes a
lot more sense
however my opponent was experienced
grandmaster
he was
grandmaster
riotsky
yeah
and
oh yeah this was the first international
open i played uh
almost 10 years ago
nostalgic
so i tried to continue with my plan and
i was slightly oblivious probably should
take him with the bishop and dealt with
that i took with the queen i'm just
showing you why this is
not good then we'll go to why what we
should do is good so
e5 see black is already beginning to do
stuff in the queen side i'm trying to
but it's not as strong
because
black does not have to cast though i'm
not forcing them into castling
so for example right now my opponent
could have considered b4 if i go g5 then
here's a bloodbath oh boy
and this would have been rather
interesting honestly for both sides i
kind of like white a little bit more
because if the bishop moves and i have
earth takes g7
and so it that's kind of why it's better
to kind of
keep hold of when to push that b-pawn
for example in the
real game my opponent just took
and i started to feel very uncomfortable
because let me tell you if i take this
then this pawn is already weak this one
is already weak
my opponent can start thinking okay
maybe i can take this
when you take back now this can be
falling b4s can exist a lot of
uncomfortable stuff are there for
example if the if d4 what do i do
if i move the knight then bishop takes
here right it's just very uncomfortable
it's not necessarily losing but it's
not something you want to play as white
especially against the grand master
anyways i went for g5 he took uh here i
should have played queen e5 just because
with queen e5 now i can maybe try to
poke around the king side a little
it's still not really you know it's not
nothing big because my queen is still
very
upset
it's be getting hunted my opponent is
attacking
my pawns and the bishops are well this
is just not the position again you want
to have as white but
this is what the game
turned to be
and
here i started to
feel a little more empowered because of
well i'm not really down on material the
position is still playable but black
definitely has more stability in the
position
and
now i'm gonna take a breather partially
because i feel like a sneeze coming up
but i need to ask you um
as white what do you think we should do
while i figure out what's going on with
the sneeze
no
it's just tickling a little sorry
poor ben simon has had my fair share of
sneezes and
and microphone so i'm ready to mute it
nah
oh
all right
nobody wants to play this as white
i feel like i've lost a bunch of
audience
i
okay
sorry leeches
you were just not letting me upload more
than six moves and
it's hard working
ah thank you dm yeah do stuff with the
apon that's what i did i went to a4
it would have been better to play
rickish one first
kind of weird right wait
am i tripping why can't they take this
seriously i feel like i'm tripping this
is
just
there's nothing here
i am tripping there is no rookish one
well i'm glad i didn't do that
a4 is good
no bishop b5 pawn just takes it there is
nothing further to it
this is i guess i was just hoping if i
could get rick h1
yeah
anyways then take
this is this would have been interesting
and this is what i did in the game but
see its opponents pieces are way too
active the rooks are just kind of in my
face
even if i go bishop g2 and then i will
have to come back because what is this
bishop doing on g2
so bishop e2 for example then that pawn
is jumping
and oh
yeah see it's kind of sad because
if i take it take
take boom
this game is giving me
taking me back to sad times so
this is actually how the game ended i
just resigned that because i mean
there's not much i can do
but
the point still stands so it's not just
about the opening it's also about the
pawn structure it's also about the piece
placement it's about the piece
activities
so this my game started to get a little
weird because after this bishop e3 so
after that
i learned more about bishop h4
but the point being
you need this bishop h4 let me tell you
why
if take this is not the end of the world
because well
you can go queen f4
now
if
pawn to g5
what do you think we should do right now
actually that's not a fair question
because we only have one good eye we
have two good ideas to do so which one
do you think is better
i prefer one to the other to be honest
um there there
there there
nikki yep what so was i
take the knight that's fair which knight
c6 or e4
if we do knight takes c6
they take
this and
this is kind of nice i would actually be
very happy with this
to be fully honest
however
i think i'm more at least in the game i
was more inclined to taking on e4 and
then taking off c6
but compared this position
with this position
right now i'm leaning more towards this
position to be honest so
i'll leave that up to your judgment now
i'm going to go back talk about not g5
what if knight g5
also to clarify this knight e4 does
exist a lot when bishop force because it
is i've seen this much more when there's
a bishop here that the bishop can't take
it
however this still exists because if you
take it
then they'll take over here and
the queen is active your knights are
under attack you just lost the pawn so
you don't want to take that queen f4 is
good
knight g5 now what do you do
there are multiple options knight c6
being one of them after take okay again
now what do you do you have one less
pawn
your castle opponent has not cast out
the center is
weirdly kind of open but not really like
you see they're open files but you can't
really break through so what should we
do
take your time
try to find the best answer
this is also quite interesting because i
remember this was actually a game that
happened to me with an opponent who was
um
i think maybe
2100 i was 23 70 something
back in um
oh my god five years ago
actually yeah because it was
early january in prague
so what do we do
what do we do
hello i'm annie
bishop d3 where are you going with that
bishop
i kind of like few other ideas maybe
something to get this queen involved
maybe use this pin
why not knight d4 exactly 94 would have
been very interesting i did not do that
because i couldn't decide what to do if
e5 or if d5 i had trouble with both of
them let's say if e5 i bring the coin
down and then they just developed the
bishop
this is too complicated and the other
part of it was what if d5 and now i have
to figure out what to do if i take take
take f6 boom g5 i mean this king is in
the middle of the board but i can't
really attack it right
so that's kind of all partially why i
also wanted to call this um
i wanted to wrap up sicilian with this
because
i didn't want to end it to the boring
line
yep it's a rouser
i i said it as a zoo
so i can add the razor in there too
but yeah
no this is what i want
so i did not do that because i love my
material way too much so clean a4 let's
attack
the idea is if queen c7 boom f4 you got
to put that nice in a corner boom f5
because you have one less pawn and the
quad king is in the center you have to
have to have to
be more dynamic and you have to start
attacking left attacking right trying to
break through a little so in the real
game my opponent played bishop d7 it's
worth noting that knight g5 is also
quite interesting because you take take
then you get this really really cool
knight d5
but still you know it's still
complicated it's not an easy game
opponent is not worse by all means we
are a little bit more comfortable
but yeah it's just so
truly weird
all right bishop d7 is um
another idea that my opponent tried to
utilize in the game now i'm gonna take a
second and ask you
why to move what do we do
oh also sorry ben i stole the cup
we usually ben usually
uses my
book
covered
mug
today i got to it first
so what do we think
let's go as white
chat is
okay take the e pawn yep you're right we
got to i mean i guess that's not a got
to type of deal but
it's a good idea
if the pawn takes
now this is very interesting
because
queen e4
and it can be followed by you want to
jump to g6 so f9 g5 check and then you
just develop so this is a very
comfortable position to be fair bishop
d3 to go for g6 is again
another great idea
and white now is definitely
slightly better still need to be able to
attack still need to be able to get your
pieces in the right spots but wide
position is better nobody here will want
to be black
i would maybe say 0.8 if i had to
estimate
maybe close to a pawn but no more than a
pawn
and i do not have engine in front of me
which kind of
feels weird i miss having engine handy
all right what if bishop takes
now what do we do
what do you think dorset did
what would dorset do
so what do we do
pin it
how i'm not going to move my d-rook i'm
going to keep this guy here
who else should we move
there we go good job by manny yep
there should be seven now again you have
multiple options
which option will you take i think i
didn't do the
best move here
i kind of should have shoulda could have
would have
d5 would not have worked because this
pawn is pinned
so you could just take it so
could maybe also with bishop
i kind of like it a bishop more actually
i don't really
i don't see that big of a difference
either one should be fine
so bishop e7 now
bishop's 87 so to be fair that is
actually what i did in the game but
there is something interesting knight
divide is fairly interesting as well
because if take take castle take take
and you just pick up c6 and it's a very
comfortable position
because this one will definitely drop
soon too and for black it's hard to form
an attack but i prefer bishop e7 because
i really enjoyed keeping the king in the
center again if queen takes kaboom
and bye bye bye bye rook
so
part to make errors
king takes now what do we do
also also keep in mind if you give black
few moves he'll do this
maybe this and fake castle
so
what do we do as white i have a rookie
one in the chat
i'm assuming this is
new for v1
what are we thinking
yeah for here okay work he one i agree
my opponent did knight f6 kaboom boom
now what do we do again this position is
really really pretty
all you got to do is figure out how to
continue it
how do we continue the attack
your rooks are in a good place your
queen
could improve
but not that much
oh queen e4 what if knight takes
queen schwartz it's an interesting point
i give you that ah there we go a knight
e4 the idea is if you were if you take
it i'll take with the queen and now the
queen is included too
my opponent uh played d5 but let's say
like what if they bring the rook there
what do you do
this is a very fun move
as white what do you do
what can we do
don't forget to think checks first then
takes moses threats and also same for
the follow-up
snap off the bishop what bishop
nikki is it possible you're a little
behind
hmm
i prefer this take the idea is you can
switch the coin to the other side and
start taking e6 and g7
same idea applies if the other rook goes
kaboom again same check and same eta
ideas
so
in the game my opponent played d5 but
let's also mention knight d5 i'm just
gonna go over just real quick because i
just really really like this you can go
c4 and bring the queen and attack this
guy it's so many so many attacks i
really really really like it
see
attack again it's like attack here
attack there that's why this position is
so good opponent's plan is so
opponent's pieces are just so up in the
air
so
uh
let's see
so in the video game we want to play d5
what do we do
what do we do
what if take on f6 i mean you can but
this also this really nice diagonal
opened up so what about that anything we
can do about that
i like that bring it to the diagonal
also maybe shift it to the other side
king moved
beautiful check
now what do we do your position is just
asking for a little bit more
a little bit more
attacks little bit more
pieces in there
i'm enjoying this
come on we got this
eat the pond there we go thank you nikki
you know i'm always hungry for ponds
actually that's not necessarily true the
club has been having some really nice
sweets on wednesdays so
all right now what do we do
you got this
dorsal have you became have you become a
member of youngster's club because of
the pawn eating
i think i've always been a
devotee of eating ponds so
i guess so yep
yeah bring it
rook f1 is fine
um queen g3 is another fine idea but my
most favorite one was just doubling up
the rook
so what do you think
i like that however it's black to move
if it was like to move knight f5 would
have been a nice idea
let's say a knight goes to e4 you can
just eat pawn right so let's say
opponent tries to put a little bit of a
hard time on us and goes pawn to c5 then
what do you do there we go queen g3
and actually here my opponent resigned
on i was going to say how do we continue
but
i guess after rookie 7 there's not much
to continue now this is one of my better
games i really enjoyed that that
specific one i really really liked it so
um
the other idea i wanted to talk about
was i'm gonna do a huge jump like a
really big jump actually this is a very
big jump talk about bishop d7 for a bit
bishop d7
it's a little bit more sophisticated
style rather than immediate e6 so if if
bishop d7 let's say you get the queen
out 96 castle defense nah what do you do
there is one thing that i've always
wanted to try but i
very rarely did
so
what do we think
ah someone is asking how is the a tree
idea
well
hmm
i'm not entirely sure ah
i think the problem is with a3 in this
specific position if you go do some
stuff like this then opponent can
immediately start playing b4 right it
just kind of gives it
a lot of issues for your queen slide
especially since you cast out that site
so that's the one thing we want to not
really rush into
all right
um
so the other thing we can talk about is
bishop takes f6 how do we like bishop
takes f6
i never did this this is the one thing
i've always wanted to do and now no one
else is actually doing it against me
so if bishop takes f6 now what do we do
yeah bishop sticks to idea let me let me
try to explain a little bit more i was
trying to get to chat to feel a little
better for it before i
uh
share up my mind if take boom f4
and now if you do you know if you do b4
or so i have knight d5 and i'm very
comfortable in this position so that's
kind of like if you want to avoid
playing a3 you can do that
all right
uh in the real game though i went to a3
also
yeah after a3 opponents played h6 now i
had to take and then i went for f4
knight d5 is another possibility but
with drug g8 i'm not so sure how i would
feel about that
all right now
let me go a little bit back
there we go after f4 my opponents went
to h5 which to be fair kind of um i got
a little bumped about it because i was
really really really hoping to
get this uh bishop e2 idea remember i
talked about maybe this
so i was really hopeful for it but i
couldn't really you know after h5 i
can't really do it so
now after h5 what should we do
i i i played this a little
too hopeful
so i played bishop e2
yeah king i'm gonna kind of go a little
faster on this because there are so many
things in this game that's
i could have done better an opponent
could have done better so i'm just going
to go a little bit faster so first thing
first what would you do with e6
keep in mind this is the pawn structure
we've already talked about a little bit
opponent king is in the center we just
can't attack it yet how can we try to
start attacking it what do you think
what do we think
exactly you gotta know your theory i
completely agree
finn
does g4 do anything not just yet i'll
give you that
um
you can play rookie one
and then you can start to consider f5s
more seriously because if f5 e5 you get
the d5 square if f5 take you get the e4e
file
if f5 they don't take you get the
tension so uh let's take a win-win
situation
in the real game opponent played better
she went rook c8
i
could have taken which would have made
it interesting but i was really stubborn
on wanting to do that f5 idea so i went
for rookie one
one and two i took and she went pawn to
e5 queen c7 was another possibility whoa
but now after pawn to e5 white to move
what do you think we should do
what do we do what do we do what do we
do
i can leave it cool enough too
and the idea is
oh apologies
the idea is
that
i
am going to play
a little more simple than that
so what i want to go ahead and do
is i want to first diffuse what black is
trying to do so black is trying to
attack me in the queen side so if i
could play like a king b1
and put the king in a little bit of a
more safety then i can spend the
remaining time bringing my forces into
queen um
into kingside center uh
master
of play f
no this is a game that i played
a while back like 10 years ago
so i'm just kind of showing you my
experience in this line
so
let me see what else do we have here
what was wrong with queen a7 uh let me
actually answer that for you
if we
if we go queen a7
i think my biggest
possible concern is
what if i have to deal with like
something like this
defending the pawn pushing over there
what should i do like that
maybe you don't want to take a6 yeah so
i mean
but if i don't want to take a6 then what
i want to do maybe knight d5
possible
see this pawn on e5 is kind of
weird because you never know exactly
what you want to do to are you going to
take it are you going to let it sit
so it's a lot of ifs and buts so
i want queen f2 i'm not opposed to coin
i7
but
i'm kind of considering i was
considering maybe i could put something
on the f file
because if i can get like a knight up
here if i take then i might be able to
you know do something like that i
probably was a little too hopeful
yeah so
oh opponent 20 point c7 king b1 queen c5
we do not own exchange coins uh-uh
now why to move what do we do we have
advantage how do we make it even better
and master oh yep
i am
trying
sometimes it doesn't pay off as fast as
i want it to
i see a knight e5 idea
i see bishop ideas nobody's saying
you're up d5 i like 25 too
yeah
and the rook t5 idea is kind of nice too
because the queen moves
now you protect your third rank you also
want to do knight d5 stuff
and
now let's say opponents played
queen c5 let's see your opponent wants
to repeat what do you do are you gonna
accept it they repeat
i like this
so
i think the idea of f5 might be more
interesting if you
kind of
thought about this position more
strategically rather than dynamically
i'll tell you what because
opponent has these two bad boys or he's
good
uh two bishops so we don't want to help
those two bishops i going to keep the
center closed we want to keep the
position closed we want to use the power
of our knights right now we do not have
a knight d5 because
i mean your problems right
so
f5 now you could start considering maybe
i can take maybe i can protect this guy
so i can freely play knight d5 it takes
a load off of your position now upon
applied bishop c6 to prevent knight d5
but it gave me opportunity to set up for
this take
however this take was not the best idea
because knight b5 would have been much
better
let me ask you what if bishop takes now
what do you do
and i'm going to switch gears and talk
about queen a5 before i
um
get any deeper
in this opening
well actually in this game because i
want to finish talking about the opening
exactly rook c3 kaboom bye bye rook
hallelujah if opponent plays rook h6 you
just got a pawn so unfortunately i was a
kid i did not know the value of pawns
and i missed it
anywho i'm gonna switch gears this game
went on and on and on and i had a better
position i blew it opponent thought much
better she blew it ended in a draw
so now we're gonna do final idea with
queen a5
and i'm going to shock you with such an
amazing move of boom
take
uh taking my taking was definitely
new to me because i want to take but
i've always done something with like
queen d2 first but right now i just
can't do this because you can you know
you can take it and force my hand into
further chase and further loss of stuff
so uh in this specific game with queen
a5 i went ahead and i took it
and my opponent took back now what
should we do right now this is a very
interesting move right now what do we do
any feelings
no feelings oh good for
all right snow
well ah thank you
brian little there we go i like that
yeah i've seen few other people mention
bishop b52 loving
knight b3 also possibility but bishop b5
says well that's much better with me
because after bishop d7 another fun idea
with queen h5 now there's an another
small idea here you want to take
if you can because uh
wait uh doesn't work it's hoping to get
a little bit more creative now my point
is if you could take it and your queen
was protected then you could take again
you gain a piece and get the queen back
so it just gives a lot of options now
opponent thought that i made a mistake
and he played a6
so now what do we do
you kind of gotta do the knight b3 at
this point you're too committed
queen gotta move you get to save the
bishop there you go oh i wish 96.
oh
i really wish but 96 are not really
attacking much so they could just take
this
unfortunately
but no not oh it's kind of let me let me
try to explain the thoughts cause this
is illegal and if this takes
ah take it then i could take over here
and pick up the queen so i wish i wish
it worked i wish 96 works no knight b3
is the best one push the queen away save
the bishop
and now my opponents play something like
e6 i long castled
started my f4 f5 business
and now question for you guys can we
take on e6
comfortably
how are you feeling
feeling good
like a shoe
yeah i need a karaoke night all right so
take
check king move take what do you do you
know you have advantage because
these pawns just suck
and
i don't have a better way of expressing
it they just suck
and your knights are comfortable
your queen is in a good position this
kink is just
pretty weak
so what do you think what do we think
what do we do now
i'll give you a small hint
try to figure out some of the uh
opponents active pieces and see if you
can exchange them off or eliminate them
ah
yes
but you have the right
thing to attack but the wrong white
piece knight d5 would beat oops
95 would be it the idea is
if you take
well then hallelujah
gotta move this horsey and then i can
just bring this oh my god this is too
good it hurts how good it is
me oh even maybe
i just want to eat this with so many
different not to the queen because the
bishop drops but this could also be
pretty nice i'm staying with e5 with the
e4 pawn though anywho opponent 20 queen
g5 they really wanted to exchange and i
was like you know what if you want to
exchange you got to pay for it now if
you take it i take it and i you know i
at least went upon
this is later in my chess career this is
like 2017 when i had started to realize
how hungry you should be
for ponds
so queen g6 was what my opponent played
i followed with the same idea i'm gonna
try to eat your palms
if you don't want to exchange queens
that's fine i'll save my clean
but i will also
start attacking you in the process
now this is one of the last critical
moves so what do you think right now
what do we do
knight d4 beautiful thank you hi manny
thank you richard yeah
with knight d4
sneeze
nah
sorry it's just very tickly it is so
cool this and louis
i think i've lost my
my
sensation
sorry everybody
one of these times it will be real
i promise you
all right so after 94
oh opponent rook c5
so now finally i get to eat stuff
that's fine we can exchange queens too i
have extra material so i'm comfortable
i'm confident i can
change this
uh
yeah
what nikki you said it's in 60s
for 20 20 degrees fahrenheit which is
like what minus
10
probably more in celsius you know how
cold that is
it's so cold my hands are peeling okay
i'm not here to complain about the
weather especially since whenever i'm at
the chest club i crank it up to 70
something so
all right
it is freezing it's so cold
yeah
anywho um
after rook f2
what now
opponent's play drink h7
again this is far outside of uh the
typical rouser but the pawn structure is
kind of the same it's the ideal pawn
structure
so
let's go up
let's attack a little left a little
right yasser style
i actually don't know why i think that's
yesterday's style it's just he's i just
always remember whenever he's playing um
i've seen you play friendly games and
he's just like little here a little
there little pond here little pond there
anyways
um i managed to secure another beautiful
pond save my pawn attack on this was i
was cute i was hopeful too
uh opponents trying to exchange stuff
whoa whoa that was not true i was
hopeful for more this than that
and again
eat another pawn push a little
attack a little this is such a good game
why didn't i show this before
but
the rating difference wasn't that much
it was about 400 points but my opponent
was uh 1950 he wasn't a
you know he wasn't a beginner he knew
what he was doing but my point is that
just because of how comfortable i was
out of opening just because of a few
ideas that i had with which critical
pawns to attack aka play f4 five is
white keep those pawns secured and
double on the f and
enjoy that's diagonal with a queen
having a queen or a bishop on h5
attacking the f7 con i had a very
comfortable game my opponent didn't
really stand much of a change here and
yeah
that is
the last of sicilian
tearing up now i'm kidding
it was a fun i'm so glad sicilian is
over i'm not going to be doing another
opening for at least
another month because i cannot talk
about this much opening
but
most likely uh we'll do a nice selection
of puzzles next week so we can just
wear off the opening
and
i would like to do a mini mini end game
series so let me know your thoughts in
the comments below if you have any
questions from
any of the openings that i've done so
far leave a comment below i actually
started reading the comments i've seen
some very
uh unique ones but for most parts
they're really i like the comments thank
you keep leaving them
like share
subscribe
and if you're going to be here for
another hour
and if you have a game for me to watch
switch to twitch meet us there in about
10 minutes
have a game in leeches link and send it
if not see you next week
[Music]
you